loans is a little look-see did you have  a rough day paging fury I'm gonna need  clarification on this space invasion  Scrolls are infiltrating your planet  they're shapeshifters  [Music]  okay prove Vietnam scroll as a photon  blast and I'll scroll can I do that I'm  just supposed to take your word today  [Music]  we are crate strong United  remember control  they have this power  but I don't know where it came from  I've never seen anything like her you  think you can find us  she's just the beginning  you come a long way not as strong as you  think  what is this she logo does announcing  your identity on clothing help with the  covert part of your job said the space  soldier who was wearing a rubber suit  get tickets now